a really great moment of bipartisan
solidarity over the weekend all five
living former presidents appeared
together you had Jimmy Carter you had
both bushes you had Bill Clinton you had
Barack Obama they all got together they
arranged their schedules to go to Texas
at the same time to raise money for the
victims of the multiple recent
hurricanes they were raising money for
Texas they were raising money for
Florida and Puerto Rico and the US
Virgin Islands incredibly rare right
that you get all five presidents
together in the same place at the same
time Donald Trump was playing golf
Donald Trump was playing golf while
Florida and Texas are reeling from
billions of dollars in damage deaths the
United States Virgin Islands have power
outages still they have water shortages
the island of Saint John is in complete
darkness now for more than 40 days
Puerto Rico total humanitarian crisis
17% power restored in Puerto Rico seven
83 percent of Puerto Rico has no power
29% of Puerto Rico doesn't even have
water there are food shortages animal
born bacteria causing illness and the
five presidents coordinate their
schedules and logistics to be there and
the president now the one former or
living president who is formally
involved in the recovery effort played
golf at one of his own golf clubs
funneling even more of taxpayer money
into his family businesses in Virginia
the 74th day as president that he has
spent at one of his own golf clubs so
far he's not a good person and he's
completely and totally delusional he was
recently asked to grade his performance
through the federal relief effort of
these hurricanes and he gave it a 10 on
Thursday the only way
Trump's federal hurricane relief effort
gets a 10 is if we're talking about a
scale out of a hundred a ten out of a
hundred maybe uh and 'la David Johnson
who died tragically in the Nazaire
ambush much controversy around Trump's
handling of that his burial was Saturday
you
got his burial taking place and you've
got five former presidents getting
together to raise money and Donald Trump
is golfing and you know in the golf
criticisms we often talk about the money
spent the money spent on Trump security
and travel and all of this stuff but I
want to take it a step further if you're
President of the United States and
you're a 71 year old man why do you want
to play golf so much if I were the
elected leader of a world superpower
like the United States I wouldn't even
be thinking of just knocking around a
little white ball this often and the
reality when when you actually it's a
fair criticism that the guy is totally
disconnected from what's going on in
these parts of the world he'd mess up
the fundraiser if he showed up he'd show
up in Texas push Obama and Bush out of
the way and start patting himself on the
back and rambling incoherently about how
great things are going and how Puerto
Rico should be congratulated because
after all it wasn't as bad as Katrina in
some sense it's better when Trump plays
golf although it's still completely
insensitive and hypocritical but
probably better for the United States in
the end send me your thoughts I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program is made possible in part
by policy genius shopping for life
insurance just kind of sucks but the
truth is if you're an adult maybe with a
mortgage particularly one with kids you
really should be looking into life
insurance but it is very very easy to
put it off because the shopping can be
really very confusing it takes a while
sometimes you have to speak to an agent
to get a quote policy genius lets you
compare life insurance from the top
providers all online in as little as
five minutes or if you're busy one
minute a day for five days and if you
find a policy that you like and you want
to know more you can then talk to one of
policy geniuses licensed experts but if
you're just browsing you don't have to
talk to anyone you can just browse away
and they don't just do life insurance
you can get disability insurance
renter's insurance pet insurance and
also compare health insurance plans so
if you need life insurance but you've
been putting it off
try policy genius
genius.com because you should only be
forced to speak to an agent if you've
committed a federal crime I like that
policy genius.com